[Music]  Northwest and Penelope Disick celebrate  their birthdays together Disney style  [Music]  the cousins had a joint molana' themed a  birthday party over the weekend how are  you look so beautiful  both girls dressed up in character Kim  Kardashian's pals including Daphne joy  shared tons of snaps from inside the  party which featured a petting zoo a  bounce house surfing contraption rainbow  snow cones  a visit from some characters from the  movie and Jaden Smith love birthday  North turn to four earlier this month  while Penelope turns five in July the  girls got matching puppies as gifts for  their big days  [Music]  you